[Applaudissements]
grâce à total sa valeur tous les gars
sont persuadés david guetta savez yaris
le groupe il fait nuit se lève il fait
nuit comme sa douce sans déconner c'est
tracera que tu as quand il fait nuit il
est 5 heures de l'après midi
tu es encore aux tartes et tranquille tu
es sur ton ordinateur et là tu bois qui
fait une vidéo tu fais patricia lyon va
s'en griller une mais peut-être pas
dehors là il fait un petit peu nuit là
sans rigoler j'ai l'impression qu'il est
4h du mat c'est une race radio tu vas
prendre une cigarette a l'impression de
se mettre dans faites entrer l'accusé
qu'un gars qui va te mettre un couteau
qu un truc comme à ce nom mais sans
laisser un coup d'oeil à mener la race
car je n'étais pas bien j'étais dans le
sud ce week-end à eybens parraine il
fait nuit
moi je fais nuit partout je rends les
enclos gère en espagne toutefois la
ville ces jours ci on pouvait vous
recoucher ça nous arrangerait
[Applaudissements]